ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนก็นักเรียนก็กลับมาเจอ
กับเรา 2 คนหรอในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะใน
วีดีโอระดับบีกินเนอร์ขาค่ะใส่แล้วหน้าขา
ก็ครูปลาฮะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันศุกร์
เย้
วันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้า
วันศุกร์ที่ 4 ค่ะอย่า 4 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตอะไรคะมีผช 2565
เมื่อ
ปีคศอะไรคะ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะจัด 2060 เมื่อวานนี้วัน
อะไรคะครูฟ้าเมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
3 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพต
ตีผช
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับลุงฟ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
กับ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 5 ค่ะเดือน
เมื่อเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ
ปีคศ 2  022 หักค่ะ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
[เพลง]
สิบโมง 55 นาทีนค่ะ 10 โมง 55 นาทีอ่ะ 10
โมง 55 นาทีนเป็นเวลากลางวันใช่ไหมคะกลาง
มวลดอกผู้หญิงเทพร้อนไหมคะ
กรุงเทพฯประเทศไทยประเทศไทยก็เท่ากับ
ประเทศไทยร้อนไหมคะประเทศไทยร้อนนิดหน่อย
ค่ะ
ร้อนหน่อย 4
35 องศาเซลเซียสซึ่งนั้นเดี๋ยวๆตอนที่
ไหนร้าน
ของไม่รู้
31 ออก 31 กับโทษค่ะสามารถ
คิดว่าน่าจะฝนตก
เฮ้อฝนจะตกใช่ไหมคะ
ไปหาประทุเจาะ
แล้วอเมริการ้อนไหมคะอเมริกา
หนาวค่ะครูฝา
หนาวหรอคะผู้หญิง
นี่ค่ะเดี๋ยวให้กูป๊าดู 2 องศาค่ะมองไม่
เห็นเห็นไหมคะ
2 องศาสา
ค่ะวันนี้นะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยกับครูฝาครู
หญิงแล้วนะเนาะก็มีคำถามจะมาถามครูฝาค่ะ
ถามว่าอะไรคะคลิงถามว่าถ้าถ้า
ตรงฟ้าแล้วก็ครูหญิงด้วยนะถ้าครูหญิงแล้ว
ก็ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีเงินมีเงิน
กี่บาท
กี่ดอลล่านาฬิกาที่บาท 10 ล้านบาทสวย 10
ล้านบาทนะโอ้โอ๋เยอะไหมครูฟ้าเงิน 10
ล้านบาท
เยอะมากค่ะครูหญิงใช่ถ้าก็เลยมีคำถามไงมี
คำถามถ้าครูหญิงก็ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีเงินสิๆ
ร้านบางรัฐ
เราจะทำอะไรเราจะซื้ออะไร
เดี๋ยวขอ Share  screen ก่อนนะคะ Green
ต้องแคร์สตรีมใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าครู
ฟ้ากับครูหญิงนะคะก็จะวาดว่าว่าครูหญิง
กับครูป๋าจะซื้ออะไรจะได้ใช่ไหมคะจะเห็น
เนาะกูว่ากำลังเชื่อมต่อแอปเปิ้ลเพนซิลนะ
คะแป๊บนึงนะมันยังไงนักเรียน
OA
ถ้าเราเนาะมีเงิน 10 ล้านบาทน้องเก่าจะ
ซื้ออะไรครูฟ้าถ้ามีเงินครูฟ้าจัดซื้อ
อะไรคะอย่างแรกมีเงิน 10 ล้านบาทขอ
ดูฟ้าจะซื้อ
บ้านค่ะอ๋อ
เดี๋ยวนะ
ป้าสีเหลืองเลยเหรอสักบาท
ครูฟ้าจะซื้อบ้าน
ว่าหน้า
ร้อนซื้อบ้านครูฟ้าสีฟ้าจัดซื้อบ้าน
ที่ไหนคะพัทยากรุงเทพ
เชียงใหม่ภูเก็ต
คิดไหม
ว่าจะซื้อบ้านที่พัทยาไม่ๆๆซื้อไปที่
กลุ่มเก็บหากรุงเทพซื้อบ้านที่กรุงเทพฯ
กรุงเทพฯเพราะว่าที่พัทยาฟ้ามีบ้านอ๋อแต่
กรุงเทพไม่มีบ้าน
ก็คิดว่าจะซื้อบ้านที่กรุงเทพฯค่ะ
เลยอย่างที่ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงล่ะคริง
เหมือนครูฟ้าเลยนะครูหญิงต้องจะซื้อบ้าน
ค่ะครูฟ้า
บ้าผู้หญิงก็บ้านสีฟ้าและซื้อบ้านสีฟ้า
เลยค่ะเป็นก็ซื้อบ้านค่ะครูฟ้าเป็นบ้าน
ไหมคะอันนี้บ้านเหรอ
กริยาซื้อบ้าน 2 ชั้นก็ได้ค่ะเหงา
ฉันแล้วก็ 2 ชั้นนะคะซื้อบ้านค่ะบ้าน 2
ชั้นแล้วครูหญิงจะซื้อบ้านที่ไหนคะที่
พัทยาอเมริกา
เชียงใหม่จะซื้อบ้านที่เชียงใหม่ค่ะน้อง
โอ๊ตภูเขาภูเขาภูหิวข้าวโอ้ย
ภูเขาค่ะเพิ่งจะซื้อบ้านบนภูเขาที่
เชียงใหม่ค่ะตัวฟ้า
ผู้หญิงชอบผู้เขาล่ะคะภูเขาค่ะ
อย่างที่สองครูฟ้าจะซื้ออะไรคะทำไมรูปฝาก
รูปอาร์ตจะซื้อ
เดี๋ยวลบก่อน
ซื้อ
รถอะไรหนู
ครูป๋าจะซื้อรถ
ครูฟ้าครูสารจะเสร็จรถอะไรคะอ่ะอาหมวย
พญาวันเล็กๆนะไม่ให้ผู้หญิงก็เลยแล้วก็
คือว่าคนเดียวหมดเลยเหรอคะ
พี่สุภาวัลย์ใหญ่
ครูฟ้าจะซื้อรถอะไร
โตโยต้าฮอนด้า Mercedes  Benz
BMW พิพัฒน์ชอบ Mini  Cooper ค่ะครูฟ้า
จะซื้อรถมินิคูเปอร์ Mini  Cooper มีไม่
ชอบมินิคูเปอร์
รถ
แล้วครูหญิงผู้หญิงจะซื้ออะไรคะอย่างที่
สองสถานที่สองครูหญิงจะซื้อ
อ่านควีนซื้อ
คอมพิวเตอร์ค่ะ
งูหนาเป็นคอมพิวเตอร์
ติดตั้งโต๊ะ
[เพลง]
น้ำเป็นคอมพิวเตอร์ตั้งโต๊ะนะคะเอาหน้าจอ
เนี่ย
32 มีไหมคะ
3  2 นิ้ว Meet  All  New หลิว 5  32
นิ้วของอา
Apple
iMac ค่ะ iMac สมัยแต่งที่ 2 ก็จะซื้อ
คอมพิวเตอร์ตั้งโต๊ะค่ะผู้หญิง
อย่างที่หามครูฟ้าคิดออกหรือยังจะซื้อ
อะไร
ครูฟ้าจะซื้อ
ซื้อ
อะไรดีอ้ะไม้
นี้เล่น
playstation  5 ขอเป็นเกมส์เสมือนครูฟ้า
จะซื้อเกม
playstation
เดี๋ยว
PS
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงปัญหาแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะคือฟ้า
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมใช่หากผู้หญิงอย่างฤทธิ์เกม
ไฟล์จะซื้อเกม playstation  5
ใช่เพลสเซอร์
[เพลง]
เครื่องเล่นเกมต่อให้บอกว่าเครื่องเกมค่ะ
อ๋อเครื่องเล่นเกมส์ playstation ก็
เหมือนกันนะคะ
ครูหญิงมาหาผู้หญิงเชื่อ
อย่างที่ 3 ครูโอ้นี่ก็จะซื้อ
กระเป๋าค่ะทรูฟ้า
นี่เนาะกระเป๋า
ระเป๋า
กระเป๋า
กระเป๋าอะไรนะผู้หญิงกระเป๋ากระเป๋าของ
ชั้นแนวค่ะคุณฟ้า
เนล
ออกกระเป๋าชาแนลซ้ายผู้หญิงชอบใช้สายๆค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเนาะอ่านี่นี่นะคะนักเรียนดูรูปนะ
คะกระเป๋าชาแนลค่ะครูป๊าหมีจะซื้อกระเป๋า
อย่างที่ 4 ครูฟ้าจะซื้ออะไรคะถ้ามีเงิน
สิล้านบาทครูฟ้าจะซื้อรองเท้าค่ะคุณหญิง
ขอซื้อรองเท้า
หรือรองเท้า
รองเท้าอะไร
รองเท้าบางเลนส์ Seiya หรือว่าบางลองเพลง
ขอดูได้ไหมคะมีรูปไหมคะว่าชอบแบบนี้อ่ะ
ออร้อ
สวนซื้อรองเท้าบาลองบาเล็นซิเอก้า
เมียแล้วแต่ประเทศนะจะเซ็นมาชอบมากชอบมาก
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงว่าให้นักเรียนจะได้รู้ว่า
ภูฟ้าจะซื้ออะไร
ไม่อยากจะรู้ใช่ไหมคะพี่ใช่ค่ะนี่ค่ะของ
เท้า
นักเรียนเข้าใจและขอดูรูปแล้วไม่เข้าใจ
เรียนที่ 4 ของครูฟ้าใช่มั้ยอะไรอย่างที่
4 ของครูหญิงนะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะอ่ะถ้า
จะซื้อ
[เพลง]
อะไรคะ
จะซื้อ
สร้อยข้อมือในเวลาที่ที่เรามีมือนี้นะคะ
หนึ่งสองสามสี่ใช่มั้ยมือเนี่ยก็จะมี
สร้อยข้อมือที่ใส่สร้อยข้อมือสร้อยข้อมือ
ของ
อะนี้ค่ะอันนี้คือสร้อยข้อมือครูหญิงจะ
ซื้อสร้อยข้อมือของ
Cartier ค่ะครูฟ้า
rt เทียวนี่
ดูนี่ใช่ค่ะเทียรึเปล่านะคะใช่ค่ะ
เห็นหลังคาที่ค่ะที่เห็นก็ไม่รู้นะคะว่า
แบบนี้เนาะนี่สร้อยข้อมือของ Cartier ค่ะ
อ่ะ
ว่าเจ้าที่ 4
ครูสาระนะคะอย่างที่ 5 ครูฟ้าจะซื้ออะไร
กูฟ้าจะซื้อ
เซตแค็มปิ้งส์หรือว่าอุปกรณ์แคมปิ้งห่า
เหมือน
เวลาไปภูเขายังไงก็ต้องมีก่อนแคมปิ้งใส่
ใจๆก็เป็นแคมปิ้งใช่ไหมแคมปิ้งปิ้งมิติน
แล้วก็มี
เอาไว้ไปแค้มป์ปิ้งค่ะอ่า
นั่นแหละอุปกรณ์ปิ้งของโปรฟ้าใช่ไหมคะ
เป็น
สิ่งมาให้นะคะเต้นกับเซ็ตแค้มป์ปิ้งใน
ห้าง
อะไรก็ได้เซ็ตแคมปิ้งไงคะครูฟ้าอ่ะ
คุณครูหญิง
อย่างที่ 5 ใช่ไหมคะอย่างที่ 5 ครูหญิงจะ
ซื้อ
โซฟาค่ะสูงไกลลูกอ่อนไม่ใช่ค่ะโซฟาที่เอา
ไว้นั่งดูทีวีค่ะครูฟ้าสู่ป่า
ฝ่านะไม่ใช่เตียงนอนนะคะ
[เพลง]
สู่ปลา
เปิดแบบไหนดู
ผู้หญิงอยากซื้อโซฟาแบบนี้นี่นี่โซฟาแบบ
นี้ใช่ไหมคะตรงนี้เนี่ยตรงนี้เนี่ยนอนได้
อยากซื้อทรงบาทดินอนได้ค่ะคือฟ้า
อย่างที่ 5 คุณครูฟ้าจะซื้ออะไรคะ
รูปฟ้าจะซื้อรถบ้าน
รถเนี่ย
รถบ้าน
เสรี 1 รถบ้านเดี๋ยวจะเป็นแบบนี้นะคะ
รถที่ขับไปด้วยนอนได้ทำอาหารได้ใช่ไหมรถ
ใหญ่ตั้งในรถบ้านเดี๋ยวจะเป็นแบบนี้
เป็นรถบ้านนะคะครูฟ้าจะซื้อรถบ้านให้เอา
ไว้ไปเที่ยวค่ะกดงานดีมากค่ะผู้หญิงละฮะ
อย่างที่ 5 ใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
ครูหญิงจะซื้อ
ซื้ออะไรดีหรอคะ
ซื้ออะไรคะครูหญิงคิดว่า
มีผู้หญิงจะซื้อนั่นซื้ออันนี้ดีกว่าค่ะ
เป็นเครื่องเล่นแผ่นเสียง
ฟริ้งเปิดให้ดูนะคะ
ได้ล้าน
เครื่องเล่นนี่ฉัน
จ่ายสายๆอ่ะค่ะนี่ดิ
แบบนี้ก็คงไม่รู้ว่ามันน่าจะไม่มีขายแล้ว
มั้งอ่ะแต่ไม่เป็นไรน้องแบบนี้นะคะเรา
เรียกว่าเครื่องเล่นแผ่นเสียงหรือว่าเป็น
ค่ะถ้าตอนนี้ใช่ไหมตอนนี้เป็น New
Technology ก็แบบนี้นะคะเครื่องเล่นแผ่น
เสียงเนาะน่าสนใจมากจ่ายค่ะเราดูว่าถ้ามี
เงิน 10 ล้านครูลูกค้าซื้ออะไรบ้างคะ
ลูกค้าซื้อบ้านนะหาซื้อบ้านเดี๋ยวแป๊บนึง
นะอ่า
[เพลง]
อะไรอ่ะเนี่ย
บ้านไงก็ฟ้าซื้อบ้านที่กรุงเทพฯชายค่ะครู
บ้านซื้อบ้านแล้วก็ซื้อรถค่ะรถรถนะคะแล้ว
ก็ซื้อเครื่องเล่นเกมค่ะ playstation  5
สวยเซชั่น 5 ซื้อรองเท้า
บาหลาดเอ้ย
ซื้ออุปกรณ์แค้มป์ปิ้งค่ะแค็มปิ้งส์นะคะ
เต้นหาเก้าอี้อะไรแบบนี้ค่ะแล้วก็ซื้อ
รถบ้านขับรถบ้านนะข้อมือผู้หญิงล่ะคะครู
หญิงเนี่ยหนึ่งหนอซื้อบ้านบนภูเขานะคะ 2
ซื้อ
คอมพิวเตอร์ตั้งโต๊ะหรอไงแม็กนะคะ 3 ซื้อ
กระเป๋าชาแนล
4 ซื้อสร้อยข้อมือสร้อยข้อมือคาร์เขี่ย
5 นะคะซื้อโซฟานอนได้แล้วก็โกหกซื้อ
เครื่องเล่นแผ่นเสียง
ท่อจะเต้นของทั้งหมดจะไม่ถ้าเรามีเงินเรา
อยากซื้ออะไรนักเรียนจะซื้ออะไรก็คอมเม้น
บอกเราได้นะคะอันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนเนาะ
แล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ